[Speaker 1]
Okay. I'm not pretty sure because I've never been to one or already, but I would
try to get some help out of someone, right? That could help me because I'm an elderly person. So
[Speaker 1]
it's, things are more difficult for us than to a young person. So I would.
[Speaker 2]
We call for help. You would call someone on your phone where we could call out for help.
[Speaker 1]
Yeah. Yeah. If that was a situation, I call for help actually. Yeah.
Well, you can say help. Help just to get me out of the flood.
[Speaker 1]
You know, the thing is like, it's like static in there because that's a tunnel and it has,
at the very end of it, it has to like higher points. So the flood comes right in between
[Speaker 1]
into the tunnel and out the tunnel.
[Speaker 2]
It's like a pool of water.
[Speaker 1]
Yeah. It wasn't like a pool that you can actually go and swim. Yeah. I will have hope. I will ask
for help actually. That's what I would do, you know, or maybe if I can, if I cannot find help,
[Speaker 1]
I will start running and trying to grab things around me so I'm not to get, you know, in the
flood and try to escape from there.
[Speaker 2]
If it flooded, I would swim because I know how to swim,
but do you know how to swim?
[Speaker 1]
Just a little bit. I get cramps whenever I try to swim, so
I'm not trying to do so because that comes terrible.
[Speaker 2]
If you don't have to, you wouldn't try.
[Speaker 1]
Yeah. And especially the water, the flood, I mean, it's kind of nasty in that part.
All the people from some parts of the city, they are thrown to that part. So I don't,
[Speaker 1]
it's not recommendable.
[Speaker 2]
I think a better hypothetical situation would be to be in a
good place with your family, someplace where you're safe and just going to get food to eat.
[Speaker 2]
That sounds like the perfect hypothetical situation.
[Speaker 1]
Yeah, I wish I could be safer than that.
[Speaker 2]
Here's a question here. We've looked at some general conversation starters
and hypothetical questions. Let's try to connect these to your own thoughts
[Speaker 2]
and potential conversations, things that you'd like to talk about.
So we can look back at these conversation starters that we've had and the hypothetical
[Speaker 2]
questions and try to think about the most interesting types of questions and how we
might answer another one in a real conversation. What type of situations would you use these types
[Speaker 2]
of questions? Let's try to categorize this a little bit more. Previously, I showed you a list
here of these different questions. The first question says, what's the most interesting
[Speaker 2]
place you've ever visited and what made it special? If you answered that question there,
when would you ask this question in a conversation?
[Speaker 1]
What kind of situation?
Well, I would like to ask somebody that I recently met. We start a conversation
[Speaker 1]
just like an icebreaking thing, right? And just to break the ice, I would start a conversation
telling, well, if I see that they're interested in that type of conversation.
[Speaker 1]
But, you know, it's like a very common thing to do, to talk about yourself when you're being
introduced or introducing yourself to somebody, right? And you're looking for questions or,
[Speaker 1]
you know, history that you can tell.
[Speaker 2]
It's great to have a question that
you can answer because then you know what you can say. But it helps the other person,
[Speaker 2]
too, if you can ask them a question like this as well. It makes the conversation go
smoother. They go both ways as well.
[Speaker 1]
Yeah. And especially that question that I answered,
which is the first one, because, you know, you start talking about your working places,
[Speaker 1]
right? And if they tell me, where have I worked? So I tell them in the airport.
So they ask me if I got to travel a lot, because being an airport employee,
[Speaker 1]
they start asking things like that. I used to work for a very small airline,
right, that works only, flights only locally here within the country. So I used to talk about
[Speaker 1]
our islands, San Pedro Sula, which is a northern point place here in the country. And that's just
to break the ice and start a conversation. I usually, or talking about their family,
[Speaker 1]
where they're from, and all that kind of stuff. Just to break the ice. That's always the same
thing.
[Speaker 2]
This is something that you're really comfortable with yourself. You've had these
conversations a lot in English. So if we need to step outside of the comfort zone a little bit,
[Speaker 2]
maybe we could ask another one of these questions. Okay. If you could choose another
question besides the first one, which question would you choose? And when would you ask this
[Speaker 2]
question?
[Speaker 1]
Okay. Let me just read them back again. Tell me about a challenge you overcame.
What did you learn from it? What's something you're looking forward to in the near future?
[Speaker 1]
What hobby or activity do you enjoy that others might find surprising? Okay. One of the things
is just to get a new job. That's one of my challenges, because even if I'm an elderly
[Speaker 1]
person, but I need to support myself. I'm not used to being supported by somebody else.
I've always been a provider, so I need to get me a job myself. And it's been hard and challenging
[Speaker 1]
to me, because as I told you, I'm an elderly person, and you know, possibilities in my country,
there are not too many for people like me or somebody else my same age and things like that.
[Speaker 1]
But, you know, the more prepared I am, the faster I'll get a job, right? But even if you study a lot
sometimes and you have a lot of experience, that's not enough in this country, because
[Speaker 1]
you've got a lot of competition with younger people well prepared for the kind of job that
we might be applying for.
[Speaker 2]
I'm really sorry to hear that it's been so challenging.
I know in many places it's a challenge for elderly people to find equal opportunities.
[Speaker 2]
But just after talking with you a few times for a few classes, I can really tell that you have
some awesome communication skills. You have some impressive experience. And if I were an employer,
[Speaker 2]
I would really be interested in your resume and your experience. You have a lot of great things
to offer and might have problems finding opportunities in Honduras, but I don't think
[Speaker 2]
you would have any type of problem finding opportunities in other places. I think you
do it. You just have to believe in yourself. We have some really wonderful skills and communication
[Speaker 2]
skills. I'm so impressed by your ability to put things into words.